[Applaudissements]
que quelques heures avant le vote
dernier rappelle aux électeurs de la
pennsylvanie pour donald trump qui avait
causé la surprise en 2016 les deux
candidats multiplient les rassemblements
depuis samedi dans cet état clé pour
l'issue de l'élection présidentielle
pour joe biden le temps est venu de
rebâtir et d'unir à nouveau le pays
les démocrates ne ménage aucun effort
même la chanteuse lady gaga est venu
prêter main forte à joe biden en soirée
cet ancien état industriel est composé
de grandes zones rurales des châteaux
forts républicain on retrouve aussi
philadelphie ville la forte proportion
d'électeurs afro américains démocrates
pas question que cette élection soit
ternie à philadelphie berceau de la
démocratie américaine
les autorités essaient de rassurer la
population qui s'inquiète des manoeuvres
de suppression du vote surtout par le
camp républicain
on promet que chaque vote se raconter et
qu'aucun électeur ne sera intimider
joseph yobo et des îles féroé au p tits
si vous tentez de volée 1000 votes
promet-il vous croupir en prison et à
tous ceux qui suivront les résultats de
la pennsylvanie un seul message patience
est en cause mais continue denis du
péché c'est ici au centre des congrès du
centre-ville de fiel elle fit que les
votes par correspondance seront
comptabilisés à partir de 7 heures
demain matin lors de l'ouverture des
bureaux de vote partout en pennsylvanie
déjà des clôtures de sécurité ont été
érigés et tous les visiteurs doivent
passer par un détecteur de métal et la
sécurité avant d'entrer les autorités
estiment que 10 fois plus d'électeurs en
pennsylvanie ont voté par la poste cette
année comparativement à 2016 et tous les
bulletins et qui seront déposés à la
poste
demain pourront être acceptés et
comptabilisés s'il arrive avant vendredi
plusieurs électeurs comme camarade et
continuent d'ailleurs de venir déposer
leur bulletin de vote par correspondance
dans certains points de chute prévue à
cet effet nous fait là un mini
rassemblement festif pour rappeler aux
électeurs noirs d'aller voter
après les divisions les tensions et les
efforts pour convaincre les électeurs
viendront la tente des résultats elle
pourrait être très longue
en pennsylvanie mais si philippe leblanc
radio-canada norristown en pennsylvanie